prioritize quiet prioritize rest
prioritize sleep and prioritize
meditation take your mindfulness and
your mindfulness practice off the mat
and into the experience of your daily
life consciously strive to be present
even for the most banal of moments and
really connect more deeply to your body
what is it telling you listen to the
signals that it's giving you pay
attention
particularly to the faint Whispers
especially when they recur and consider
them Messengers sacred foot soldiers
they are Catalyst for transformation
delivering magic when translated into
action
so listen to them and act upon them